so uh some crush of books just did an
imu uh seminar um and uh
i've been on this book tour and talking
a lot about what i'm calling the thank
you economy
i won probably more money um from
the bets i made that crush it would make
the new york times bestseller list
the top 10 the print version um
then i probably did signing the book
deal because so many people told me that
people would not buy
you know from internet brands that i put
out so much
content for free that
there's no reason to buy something like
a book and that you know
old media people thought that definitely
and then a lot of new media people who
bet me
thought i wouldn't get there because
other internet celebrities or
or social media experts have not done
well with their books
either and so what i knew
and what i'm powerfully excited about is
what i call the thank you economy
i think we're headed towards the thank
you economy see content
though king and though probably more
important than ever because i think
every business needs to be in it
the cost and value of it has completely
plunged
because it's classic economics of supply
and demand
there's so much more supply now that the
demand to pay for it is considerably
lower
however it is the foundation of giving
you the ability to bring people into
your community
and then you have to really care for
them and love them
i know that 80 of the people that bought
this book and i know that a bunch of you
that are watching now are going to buy
more books in the holidays give us gifts
not because it's the greatest book ever
though it's pretty darn good i think
but because of the thank you economy
because you're going to thank me for 800
episodes of wine library tv you're going
to thank me for the hundreds of gary
vaynerchuk videos
you're going to thank me for all the
keynotes that i put out and all the new
streams i've done
and for all the tweet backs and for
answering every email
and i know i'm in july right now so i
apologize i'm trying to catch up
it's a thank you economy get great
service care about people and you'll win
i mean zappos they weren't the cheapest
they just cared and they built a pretty
darn big business
so what i know is that the thank you
economy is coming
if you don't give real customer service
if you don't love your customer
you're gonna be in a very different
place because word of mouth is how
brands are built and business is done
and word of mouth is now on steroids my
friend word of mouth
is now completely exploding we're
connected more than ever
soon will be connected worldwide more
than ever soon will be connected on the
mobiles
more than ever and the fact of the
matter is word of mouth
is going to change branding and caring
and good customer service
from your cashier to your truck driver
to your ceo
is going to be the game the thank you
economy